hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it's november 18th 2021 we are
live streaming
what did i say it's not it's not nobody
oh
that's on you man they screwed me it's
december 2nd that tells you everything
you need to know about the teleprompter
like i know the date but then you put
that freaking thing
that no lunch for you man
michael's not getting any lunch you
screwed me good michael
it is december 2nd 2021.
thank you very much
uh we are live streaming on rumble we're
live streaming on youtube and on blaze
tv uh and actually today's a huge day um
if you have not heard the news already i
suspect that most of you have uh because
it's breaking and it's sort of just
going across the internet in a crazy way
as these viral moments do uh rumble
which of course as you know uh locals my
company merged with rumble about six
weeks ago our feeling was we wanted to
combine forces with another
sort of mission aligned company to fight
for the free speech principles that i
believe in and espouse on this show all
the time and to fight for a free and
open internet uh which is sort of what
the promise of the internet was 20 years
ago but certainly not what the internet
has become
under the thumb of big tech giants like
youtube and google and facebook and
everybody else well that happened about
six weeks ago that big merger and it's
made both of the companies stronger and
bigger and our growth is great and all
of that good stuff and as you may have
seen uh the story originally broke last
night but then really has sort of caught
fire today rumble has now combined with
cfvi which is cantor fitzgerald and i'm
sure many of you know
or have heard of cantor fitzgerald
they're a financial services firm
and they're sort of
most known unfortunately
outside of the financial world
that they were one of the companies that
on 9 11 they were
office their office was in the twin
towers one of the buildings and 658 of
their employees
actually died on 9 11. so that's why if
the name rings a belt you it might be
because of that i lived in new york city
at the time uh obviously uh everybody
sort of knew
that story but that's not what this is
about they they've rebuilt the company
sort of beyond crazy circumstances uh
and now uh rumble
through cfei is going public and is
being traded as we speak right now so i
just want to be clear about a couple
things first off i am in no way giving
anyone any kind of
investing advice at all nothing like
that but i do want to just say a couple
things about what's going on here in the
fight against big tech and then sort of
i'll answer some questions i saw that we
already have a couple questions about
the merger and all that good stuff uh
look we all know something's wrong with
the internet we all know it we all know
there's something wrong with the way
we're communicating with each other we
all know that certain things are
demonetized certain things are
de-boosted certain things are regulated
and odd ways you guys know if you're
watching this on youtube that if you
subscribe to my channel and you click
that notification bell as i often remind
you to do you know that you don't see my
videos right like we don't know how the
algorithm manipulates us so that if
you're watching one thing could they
feed you 20 other things to push you in
a particular political direction or
could they show you things that are
counter to that to push you in another
direction we just don't know we know
that this is all like oddly combined
with mainstream media and it's all just
kind of gross and truly guys the mission
of rumble and locals uh for as long as i
am uh part of this and for as long as
chris who is the ceo is part of this and
i had a long conversation with with it
about him with him about it this morning
um our goal will be to have uh a fair
internet you're allowed to say what you
want politically if you want to say
something about an election that's okay
if you want to say something about a
vaccine that's okay you can't break the
laws you can't plan a terrorist attack
right you can't directly threaten
somebody something like that and if you
do those things you got bigger problems
than say rumble
or locals but we want to build a
parallel eco system i am not here to
destroy youtube or google or anything
else we just want to build better
products that's why we did this that's
why we're combining forces that's what
cfbi
is all about and i'm thrilled to say
that you know i'm in this with dan
bongino who put up a really fantastic
video about it this morning and uh we're
gonna fight we're gonna do the best we
can and you know what when you're in a
fight
sometimes you need some other people
right you need to find people that have
some money you need to have you find
people that have some resources and you
hope that you're all ideologically
aligned enough to build something bigger
than what you've all built i think
that's what we've done here
so let me leave it at that for now i
know we have a couple specific questions
about that and before we get to the q a
today i did want to talk about that
great man from florida yes
that ron desantis who basically
single-handedly is uh saving the united
states by making florida a shining
beacon
for freedom in this country i mean it
really really is true like you listen to
what this guy is doing versus pretty
much what everyone else is doing and
it's like there's just there's just no
comparison uh so desantis really
yesterday gave a great speech just
ripping into biden over covid policy and
you know my policy about kovid i'm only
going to show you things about covert
that hopefully are going to inspire you
or really show what hypocrites these
people are i think this is one of the
inspirational ones here's ron desantis
this is a guy who demagogued donald
trump all of last year saying kovid was
trump's fault if you elected him he
would shut down kovit well that hasn't
happened okay you right now you see
massive waves in michigan and in maine
and some of these other places and you
see waves taking off in other states in
the northeast and that's just the
reality and so
uh
he basically sold the public a bill of
goods said that he would shut it down
he's not shutting it down so what
they're doing now i think is just it's
not going to have any impact
on on mitigating covet it's more more
theater and so all the mandates have
been put on hold none of those were
constitutional
and now you're going to have potentially
more restrictions at least they're not
going to go through with the insane idea
that all americans would have to
quarantine for seven days upon coming
back into the united states even if
they're vaccinated even if they tested
negative that was actually under
discussion that would have been
absolutely ridiculous if that was the
case and so florida
we have the the lowest coveted rate in
the country uh for cases but then if you
look just infections in the covidestem
project which is yale harvard stanford
they don't look at just cases they look
at all the because most infections
aren't documented with case counts
they have florida right now as one
infection for every hundred thousand the
lowest in the country and there's some
states that are 120 130 infections per
100 000 and so but a lot of those places
that have the high infections they have
mandates and they have passports and
they have all these things and so i i
just think we need to get real here and
we should not be imposing any type of
mandates
or restrictions on the american people
especially when
you don't do that for people that are
coming into the country illegally
okay so there was obviously a lot more
of that that we could have showed you i
felt two minutes was probably enough you
got the idea there i think one of the
things that's most impressive about
desantis is that he does all of that
pretty much without a lot of notes in
front of him notice he doesn't look down
a lot there are no prompters in that
area right he's not looking anything
he's got a set of information he's
reciting it uh he's telling you what he
thinks and it's very obvious that he
believes what he says he references
studies like the guy really is on the
ball you may remember a couple weeks ago
i was at a fundraising dinner for him
and i was super impressed just an hour
going on and on about everything and
again with references and data points
and all this and then doing an
uncensored q and a right after and then
i had the honor
even though i don't think politicians
are above us but i had the honor sitting
next to the guy at dinner and it was
like he just took question after
question
pulled no punches he's just the real
deal couple points that he made there
first off that the mandates are not not
constitutional and that is true the
government cannot force companies to
force their employees to inject
themselves with things they can't do
that this is now hung up in the courts
you all know about that the daily wire
is leading uh the case on that through
harmeet dylan who's a wonderful lawyer
who i've had on the show and a friend of
mine so we are now fighting those things
out but desantis is saying hey we're
just not going to be part of it we're
not going to be part of that here in
florida we have rules we have laws and
we're just not going to be part of this
federal mandate nonsense which isn't
even in effect at the moment he also
makes a point this insane idea about
everyone quarantining you may remember a
couple days ago we played that video
from fox news peter ducey talking about
how they were about to lay out all of
these new regulations and restrictions
and there were rumors about new
lockdowns coming and a whole bunch more
and i said i didn't want to get too into
it because who knows how much of this is
just a rumor right now versus reality
now it sounds like they're not going to
force everybody who comes into the
united states to do this self quarantine
for seven days not that there's any real
way to make sure that people are
actually doing it or that anyone would
do it or anything else but the point is
they float these ideas and then guess
what happens then there's pushback right
like i mentioned it on the show other
people mention it and they go oh the
people aren't all sheep maybe we're
pushing a little too hard here so
they're not going to do that which is
great uh and then finally of course he
mentions that florida now has the lowest
covid rate
in the country the lowest coveted rate
in the country so that's what's
happening over in florida while gavin
newsom as you know extended his uh
emergency powers here in california and
then went on a 200 000 dollar vacation
with his family
you tell me what type of person uh you
want in the government working for you
because that's what they're supposed to
be doing working for you i think the
answer is pretty clear all right guys we
got a ton on the q a and of course if
you want to get questions in last minute
you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com you can text us
chat with us right now helen can get me
messages through that prompter that had
the wrong date on it a moment ago you
can get me questions directly and we've
got a whole bunch to get to but before i
get to the q a i want to talk to you
guys about ladder you know i want to
talk for a minute about things that have
fundamentally changed the way we live
these things are the disruptors things
like smartphones streaming services or
dogs named clyde who like to jump on you
each time you come home and he's a boxer
and he also punches and he's punched me
in the nuts many times another disrupter
i heard of recently is a company called
ladder who basically took the life
insurance industry flipped it upside
down and shook out the inefficiencies
before ladder if you wanted to get life
insurance you had to drive across town
fill out a ton of paperwork and then
wait six to eight weeks to find out if
you've been approved you also receive
you'd also receive a zillion phone calls
from agents trying to bundle your life
insurance with things like car insurance
now with ladder you can get fast
affordable life term insurance without
leaving home
it's a hundred percent when you apply
for three million dollars or less in
coverage no doctors no needles no
paperwork so if you've been if so if
you're between the ages of 20 and 60
need coverage and want to team up with a
company that's redeeming life insurance
choose ladder the process is super quick
and easy go to ladder ladderlife.com
reuben today and see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com reuben
ladderlife.comrubin and now back to me
how we doing over there we're having
some technical craziness i got an error
on the prompter my my mic was a little
low there's a lot going on we have a lot
going on right now in this studio and uh
it's just
okay here we go ruben report q a yeah uh
we got a gajillion questions roughly and
uh i'll take as many as i possibly can
brian allen says how's hanukkah in l.a
you know it's been a pretty uh
uneventful hanukkah i'd say tonight's
night five of hanukkah eight crazy
nights of course hanukkah is the story
of a couple jews known as the maccabees
who were in the judean hills uh which is
now known as the west bank that's a
place that rashida talib and aoc and
ilhan omar don't want any jews to live
in but it's a story from about
2500 years ago about 2 500 years ago
where those crazy jews in the judean
hills odd that it was called the judean
hills it makes me wonder who lived there
back then uh was defending their own
land and their livelihood and way of
life and culture uh from the greeks and
they won and then you know the oil and
the eight days and the whole thing so
you eat uh you eat latkes and uh you eat
donuts and other fried food and honor
that it's actually been totally good
sent some fun gifts to my nieces and
nephews and uh we've we've been lighting
the candles and all that good stuff i
thank you for asking storm says with the
crazy new ceo of twitter are you looking
at other social media sites for broad
public interactions well look of course
uh well if you haven't heard for those
of you that haven't heard uh jack dorsey
the ceo of twitter he's been the ceo i
think basically from the beginning
probably for over a decade now
he stepped down from twitter this week
now look i have no love for jack dorsey
i've critiqued him many times i've had a
couple interactions with him on twitter
he had promised to do this show so that
he could publicly respond to some of the
critiques he promised me personally many
times and then just always it got lost
within once i was on emails with like
the twitter comms people it would always
get pushed and lost we can't do it now
we can't do it then blah blah blah i
think some of these people just are a
little over their heads he strikes me as
one of those guys i don't know is he
some like evil globalist who was
censoring everybody and shadow banning
everybody and everything else i don't
know but i also know you know he was
running another company i think square
is that the other company that jack
dorsey was running square it's like i
would imagine that being ceo of twitter
is probably enough of a job for one guy
and somehow he's the ceo of another
company too like that just all seemed
very odd to me but they have a new ceo
now a couple of his old tweets have
appeared and it seems like he may not be
that friendly to uh free speech in
general uh he's actually made a couple
points about how twitter should not be
about free speech it should be about
more of like safe communications and
cleaning up public discourse things of
that nature which are just orwellian
terms to say hey we're going to censor
people we don't like so i don't have a
lot of faith that twitter is going to be
in good shape i suspect i'll be banned
at some point i would suspect anyone
that's a free thinker at any level would
be that's exactly why i started locals i
mean everyone should have an off ramp so
you know join us at rubenreport.local
it's absolutely free to create an
account download the app you'll be able
to stay in contact with me and then if
you want to throw in a couple bucks to
interact to get some you know bonus
content early stuff things of that
nature that's great and then you also
support the show help keep us
independent that's one way but everyone
needs their off-ramp right now like
these social media sites are coming for
everybody and of course i can link this
back to where i started today this is
exactly why we merge with rumble we want
to build a better ecosystem we want to
build parallel rails and better
companies you know
again this is why i don't always attack
these guys directly it's like i sort of
feel bad like you're the ceo of twitter
you're like this tech guy next thing you
know you're like you're basically
running an empire and you don't even
know how much power you have and how
ubiquitous all this stuff is and it's
like
i don't know like it doesn't seem like
the most fun thing in the world now they
get paid [ __ ] tons of money for it okay
fine um but you know this all none of us
knew what the internet was going to do
to the entire world 20 years ago now we
have a lot of information so i think we
can build better companies right now
that is our goal with rumble and locals
it really is that simple
so i know we have a couple more on that
so i won't go too far cheryl says
there's boatloads of hope that people
will wake up and a red tide will sweep
the country in 2022. given the amount of
voter fraud and corruption in many of
our larger cities and the collusion of
mainstream media to keep people
uninformed do you think this is false
hope what can we do to make uh that what
what can we all do to make that change
in the face of the leftist machine so
this is a great question obviously it
does seem as bad as things are coveted
lockdowns omicron unicron megatron sound
wave it all sounds very scary right like
none of us are happy about the mandate
it's like there's so much
evil just like floating in the ether
right now it's not good but a lot of
people are waking up a lot of people are
waking up it's like
two years after all this started do you
think the government deserves more of
your money do you think nancy pelosi
deserves more power over you like do you
think these people care about you i
think a lot of people are realizing you
have to be reliant on yourself you have
to be relying on your family your
community you have to figure out ways to
not be so beholden to big tech or big
media or whatever it might be you may
have to grow some food learn how to do
some things by the way this is very much
what my what my next book is all about
don't burn this country which comes out
in april um but you you ask an
interesting question which is okay so if
there's a lot of people waking up and we
want to take power back to the people
and by the way that's what happened in
virginia with glenn yonkin obviously
there's parents showing up to school
board meetings fighting against critical
race theory like there's a lot of good
markers out there in the distance and it
can be hard to see them sometimes
through like just you wake up and
there's just like the outrage of the day
or the scary variant that's coming to
kill you and everyone you know
um but the real question here is um do
we trust uh that the system won't
fortify the election remember that
article after the election last time
that they didn't steal the election was
that in the atlantic the fortify the
election article i think it might be
maybe it was the atlantic or the new
republic they didn't steal the election
they just had industry leaders and
journalists and activists and non-profit
groups fortify the election to make sure
that orange hitler would not become
president again and have a second term
of evil which now seems like the
greatest four years
like it seems like a dream those four
years doesn't it relative to like the
lunacy that we're dealing with now um so
i think the best thing we can do is get
more involved you know you got to speak
up and you got to get involved like
nobody's coming to save you
there's a couple good politicians out
there obviously desantis is like is like
the gold standard for what a governor
should be doing
in his state to care about the people
that are in his state and to make sure
that they can live as freely as possible
and they're flourishing there right now
absolutely flourishing and if you didn't
watch the show from a day or two ago we
just opened we just closed the deal on
our first studio space there so locals
as you know moved down there we moved
down there about half a year ago
but now we're also building studios in
miami so like there's a ton of good
stuff going on there find some people
that are like-minded with you figure out
ways whether it's like going to the to
the school board meetings and saying
what you think
uh whether it's starting a little
political club or maybe it's not
political but you start a book club with
people that don't want to just read you
know
leftist propaganda like there's just
ways but you got to do it and you got to
have hope and uh and i think there there
is reason for hope i really do uh
patrick says what's your favorite
christmas movie and why is it die hard
well first off i will absolutely say
i've said it on the record before and i
will say it again die hard is a
christmas movie it's obviously a
christmas movie the whole thing takes
place during christmas at a christmas
party so it is a christmas movie uh it's
a spectacular movie that is true however
what is my favorite christmas movie well
i actually just watched it i've seen it
probably a hundred times and i watched
it again on the plane ride going to
florida a couple days ago christmas
vacation chevy chase is it's perfect
it's funny it's perfect chevy chase it's
sort of 80s cheesiness you know i know
the the vacation movies the last couple
were pretty terrible you know the first
the first one original national
lampoon's vacation uh going to wally
world is perfect the european vacation
one not great christmas vacation is just
great the interactions with his parents
the in-laws the kids there's just so
much merry christmas merry christmas
kiss my ass cause his ass happy hanukkah
like there's just so much funny stuff in
there um it's it's just great and uh
yeah that is my favorite christmas movie
uh ben says did you hear about the new
santa cruz county mask mandate they just
mandated that you mask up in your own
freaking homes yes i did see it and we
did not cover it here because i decided
not to cover that sort of depressing
ridiculous nonsensical edict ordered by
no undoubtedly people who will not do
that in their house like do you think
whoever the city regulator was or
whoever it was in santa cruz that's
telling people that they have a mask up
in their own homes do you think that
there is any chance like literally any
chance that they are masking up in their
own homes of course
not much like that woman what was that
woman's name that we went to the protest
at her house who shut down sheila cool
thank you
sheila uncool
who was the city supervisor here in l.a
who voted to shut down outdoor dining
this is months ago and then literally
that night knowing that the mandate
would kick in the next day she then went
and ate outside at her favorite italian
restaurant in santa monica and it's like
you you people are just evil right like
what else can i say about you like are
you misguided are you stupid are you
[ __ ] i don't know but like you're
just evil your actions at some point are
evil because you don't even fear this
thing because you're having your your
pasta fajoul uh while you're eating
outside while you're you're shutting
down other people's businesses and
destroying other people's lives that
actually that protest which we went to i
took my whole team there uh was the very
protest that i signed the recall for
cabin for gavin newsom obviously didn't
turn out the way i want but you can't
win them all
michael says the rumble acquisition of
locals was brought up on a recent joe
rogan experience with guest tim poole
have you seen or heard about the
discussion who would you not allow to
use the platform for example terrorist
kkk gavin newsom
etc um well cavendish is obviously the
worst of those um so i did not see that
specific instant instance it must be
just in the last couple weeks because
obviously this is somewhat new news um
but i would say this first off i'm not
fully in charge of policy right like i'm
helping uh talk about these ideas and
i'm helping on the pr side but what i
can tell you is we are having serious
discussions and this is alongside dan
bongino about doing everything we can to
make sure that political discussion
that is not directly leading to violence
so terrorists he asked about terrorists
like we're not gonna hamas cannot be on
there you cannot have uh you know a
terrorist group that wants to blow up
people and main people and destroy
property and all that will not be
allowed and by the way that's a that's a
law in the united states that you can't
do that so if they were able to sneak a
video on they'd have a much bigger
problem and of course we would take that
video down are you allowed to share
noxious views you are we are trying our
best to remain politically neutral that
is the goal that is me telling you that
that is what the goal is uh if you want
to know more about that i would
recommend you check out chris pavlovsky
he is the
ceo of rumble you can check out his
twitter page where he's put a couple
statements up
and he is in control of the company okay
and assaf my partner at locals is still
running locals completely you are
allowed to put up crazy leftist woke
lunacy does the entire
for the most part like the brass of
rumble and locals do we uh uh do we
believe in those ideas of course not but
we're not here to censor people right
like that was the problem it was like if
youtube that day on day one had said hey
you know we're pretty much woke and
lefty and we are going to suppress
people on the right we are going to push
people on the left and we're going to go
for all this diversity inclusion and
we're going to you know do all these
algorithmic tricks well then we all
would have known what the score was or
not even the score we would have known
what the rules are at the beginning and
then we could have acted accordingly
right we could have said oh maybe we
shouldn't be on these platforms or maybe
we do have to figure out other ways of
building things or whatever else but
they pretended they were neutral our
stated goal having seen their mistakes
is to bring the most politically neutral
platform possible but you can't break
the laws of the united states so can
gavin newsom have a channel on rumble
where he can say whatever he wants yeah
can he says can he say he doesn't like
dave rubin yeah and can i have a channel
where i say i don't like avenues and
yeah and that will be the point and are
you allowed to say that you're skeptical
of elections sure and are you allowed to
say that you're skeptical of vaccines
sure and are you allowed to say you love
vaccines and you think elections are
always perfect you can say all that
stuff too so that that's my commitment
to you we're gonna do the best we can to
respect the the principles of free
speech in the first amendment uh as best
as we possibly can and it'll be it'll be
a work in progress and i also want you
to know that the reason i stuck around
because we could have sold this company
for cash we really could have when we
sold locals i could have just walked
away with a lot of cash and i didn't i
wanted to stick around i wanted to take
stock so i could stick around to be part
of this it's like this is what as dan
bongino said in his video it's like this
is what his life's work has been and has
become and i guess that's what's
happened to me too like it wasn't really
intentional uh i just started saying
what i think a couple years ago and here
i am but i promise you that dan and i
will will be as transparent as is
humanly possible
when we have new policy changes unlike
youtube and twitter which by the way
like i think it was youtube or one of
them i got an email at like 2 a.m on
friday after thanksgiving when they know
no one's checking emails about updates
of privacy policies like we're going to
try to do this better than them we're
going to build better products that's
the only way we get out of any of this
stuff tallway says how do you feel about
the fact that there are more boarded up
windows and armed guards in union square
rather than windows full of holiday
ornamentation and the seasonal
enticement of products what does that
tell you about democratic policy yeah
you're talking about union station in
new york you know i was in new york a
couple weeks ago and yeah it's weird it
was like it was like sort of open and
people were around and you're supposed
to show vaccine passports but people
didn't really care and it smells like
weed everywhere now where it used to
smell like pee and homeless people
there's more of a smell of weed
throughout the city pretty much
everywhere um
but there are still tons of boarded up
stores here in la tons of boarded up
stores it's partly that
you know companies small business mom
and pop operations and restaurants they
just can't deal with uh every couple
weeks having people break their windows
or just knowing that the government
could just shut them down you know
something like uh i think something like
two percent of first-year restaurants
succeed usually it's like an incredibly
incredibly hard thing to you know
actually create a successful thriving
restaurant now you throw in oh that the
threat of violence could come at any
moment and we're also going to tell
people that if they go outside they're
going to get sick it's very very tough
so your question is what does this all
tell you about democrat policy i mean it
tells you that it's pretty horrible look
at minnesota ilhan omar defunded the
police and now crime and murder is
through the roof and she's blaming the
police for not doing their job
in new york you know they're they're
letting people they're not arresting you
if you go into cvs and you steal 800
worth of [ __ ] they're doing it here in
la san francisco which i was at about
three four weeks ago is an absolute
dystopian nightmare so it's like you
don't have to listen you don't have to
just look at numbers to figure out what
is real and who you should vote for it's
like what do i always say now it's like
you don't
have to be
a republican but you cannot be a
democrat right i don't really consider
myself a republican but i consider
myself someone who cares about freedom
right like i don't think i have to be a
republican like i'm putting on the pin
and i'm going to the republican party
convention and what to do and here we go
and i love ronald reagan like i like a
lot of those ideas i watch a lot of
ronald reagan when i'm doing cardio you
know there you go ronald reagan um but
but you can't be a democrat right now
you just can't and would i like to see a
restoration of balance in the force yeah
it would be good it would be good if the
democrats could get rid of their worst
elements but they can't and right now
they're they're conservatives they're
basically pretty good and there's a
balance between libertarianism and old
school conservatism and the trump thing
and some more religious nationalists and
and it's all in a mix and everyone kind
of wants america to operate so the
choice is up to you
victor says as we make a run at creating
parallel structures going public is
undoubtedly the best way to raise
capital needed quickly to compete he's
obviously talking about what happened
with rumble this morning however what
steps can we take to make sure the
boardrooms of pro-liberty companies
don't become woke i'm thrilled that you
asked this question actually because
this is a legitimate concern right like
so people saw where rumble is now a
public company through
uh this deal with cantor fitzgerald
right so now there will be a board there
will be like much more money around and
many more voices and all of those things
look we are going to do the best we can
to have the right people on the board as
i said chris is going to continue to run
the company and control the company asap
is running locals and will it be
will it be impossible to make sure we're
not infected i don't know if it'll be
impossible i think we can do the best
job possibly that is that is possible if
we go in
knowing that once you let woke-ism in
once you have a diversity and inclusion
department in your company like i cannot
imagine that rumble will do that i
cannot imagine i'm going to get an email
one day and someone's going to go you
know having a diversity and inclusion
thinking dave you've got to be replaced
by a trans black lesbian on the reuben
report they don't they don't own ruben
report i'm just giving you an example
um
we're going to do everything we possibly
can to make sure that the people
who become our board members the people
who are guiding policy that they're not
wokesters um now will you allow be
allowed to be a wokester using the
product that we provide of course you'll
be allowed to be a leftist you'll be
allowed to be a progressive nut bag
whatever you're about to be a socialist
and a communist and a marxist aoc you're
welcome on rumble okay and we're not
gonna suppress your traffic just because
the stuff that you spout is bananas uh
but we have work to do so it's it's an
absolutely legitimate question it's a
great question i'm glad you asked we
have to do everything we can to make
sure that the people that are on the
board that are making the decisions that
are in all the important meetings that
we're all agreed on the basic principles
of free speech that we are not here to
put our finger on the scale and i
promise you i will do everything i can
to make sure that that becomes a reality
uh paul says will you be joining dr
jordan peterson's new tour at any point
so if you didn't hear jordan just
announced a day or two ago that he's
going on something like
140 stop tour which is pretty much
exactly what we did last time
there were about 140 shows last time i
did about 120 of them in about 20 cities
i am not going to be joining him on this
tour i just have too much
going on
as you can tell there's a lot going on
here between rumble stuff and production
company stuff and my new book and i'll
be on my own tour like
but i want to be extremely extremely
clear i wish you're nothing but the best
and i hope this tour absolutely
crushes it i hope that it is as
life-affirming and life-changing for
hundreds of thousands of people as the
last one was
i believe that his daughter michaela
will be opening up for him but jordan
did mention that if he's ever in a town
that i'm in that maybe i can do a little
guest appearance a little warm up up top
uh i do sense that perhaps in february
there's a date of a city that i might be
in at that point and you know okay okay
uh so uh yeah i i would highly recommend
you go go go see jordan he's he's back
he's sharp um he helped me change my
life and i have no doubt that by you
asking that question he helped you
change yours and that's a pretty
beautiful thing uh yitzi says what does
the rumble ipo mean for locals i mean
i've basically been talking about that
so
locals and rumble merged so in effect
they are one company we're running the
companies separately so asap who is my
partner and ceo of locals will continue
to run locals we now have more resources
so basically by going to ipo by going
public this allows us to get way more
resources we can start looking at other
companies and go man they have a good
business plan they've got good content
creators could we maybe acquire these
people and then can we help leverage the
distribution network that is rumble to
make sure there's more eyeballs on
everybody can we do that and then also
figure out a way to monetize all that we
really like subscription obviously
that's what locals does um without
having to sell people's data and you
know steal basically your digital soul
that everyone else is doing so in the
short term in terms of the product if
you like locals nothing is changing our
hope is that we will have more resources
so we can grow faster you know there's
things that we want to add that now that
will have more resources you can add
more team members we can update more
quickly uh there's a rumble app a new
rumble app is coming out which i've seen
the mock-ups for which is going to be
awesome
and we're going to do our best to pay
attention to what your needs are like
we're just doing our best i i really
promise you that um and and now by going
public you guys can be along for the
ride but again i'm not telling anyone to
do anything
whatever you do with your hard earned
money is obviously your decision
you know my feelings about the company
marissa says happy hanukkah do you think
we are headed for a civil war
so they kind of funny about the
transition there there are several
pundits pontificating this possibility
michael malus for example
do we are we heading towards the civil
war so i've been answering this in
these q a's and on some interviews that
i've been doing a civil war well first
off i would hope that we will all do
everything that we can
to not enter a civil war the problem
that we have right now
is that we have two competing sets of
ideas that are completely antithetical
to one another so in a normal situation
and for the first 200 years let's say of
america we had a basic set of ideas that
was something like this we had some more
conservative people who didn't want to
change that much at once and we had some
more liberal people who maybe did right
so if you were say liberal in the old
days maybe you wanted to more quickly
um you know get women to be able to vote
or gay people to be allowed to marry or
something like that you wanted you
wanted to maybe push change a little bit
more quickly to get people to true
equality
from my position this is a
this is a positive goal and we've
accomplished it in america there is no
one in the united states of america that
is a legal citizen here that is treated
differently under the law it doesn't
mean it's easy for everybody and it
doesn't mean we're all born the same way
or some of us are born rich some of us
are born poor some of us have great
skills some of us some people are born
sick i mean there's all that stuff
that's like just the gestalt of life
okay
but america has done everything it could
to realize its promise of equality for
everybody and then it's your chance
right
then and then hard work and being a
decent person some of that stuff matters
and you can go out and do the best thing
possible so we had conservatives and
liberals fighting over different things
should we
the abolitionists free all the slaves
right now versus some of the people that
said we can't do it right now it'll turn
into complete tumult and we can all look
back and go okay those are the bad guys
and those are good guys but the point is
there was this agreement that america as
a as a country the idea of freedom and
individual rights and god-given rights
that it was good and it was purposeful
and it was meaningful and that's why so
many people came here that's why all the
success of america is great it's why no
one leaves america you you guys know all
that stuff now we have a set of ideas
that comes in which is this woke marxist
communist socialist stuff whatever you
want to know that is that is
antithetical to those ideas because it
is based in collectivism that the group
is more important than the individual
and the individual is the most important
thing in a
free society right like if individuals
are free they will figure out what
relationships work from them bottom up
and we can build good things and that's
what we've done but now we've got this
collectivist borg that these people want
just keep giving this machine power and
it will somehow control us in a good way
and of course it cannot be perfect as
they always promise for their utopia
because we are imperfect and imperfect
creatures cannot create perfect systems
which is why you've got to kill an awful
lot of people in the name of
socialism and communism and nazism and
probably woke-ism and the rest of it you
get it so
as to a civil war well the difference of
our old problem was okay liberals and
conservatives change a little bit i
don't want to change that much like okay
but we all think america is kind of good
and let's agree that this thing's pretty
decent and let's not all destroy it okay
that's the way we've operated for most
of the years now we've got this thing
that tells you america's founding is
evil we're systemically racist the
patriarchy capitalism is evil they have
absolutely no respect for any of our
institutions or the separation of powers
i mean just listen to what they're
saying about the supreme court right now
as all this abortion stuff's going on
it's like this is a real problem because
there's a set of people who are
basically they're basically cobra
commander from the old gi joe cartoon
remember every episode of gi joe ended
with cobra commander trying to control
the world right he'd have a weather
machine or some crazy space laser or
some underground thing and he wanted to
control the entire world and then at the
end he couldn't get it so if i can't
have it nobody can and that's sort of
what they want to do meaning they want
to just destroy the whole damn thing if
they don't get everything that they want
so are we going to end up in some sort
of like cold civil war situation
probably we're probably in it right now
you know and it doesn't mean that we
have neighbor attacking neighbor
although in some cases we do in
wonderful progressive cities
and i would hope it would never come to
anything that would be any more
physically violent like we got to figure
out ways but the thing is if if you want
to be left alone and the other guy just
doesn't want to leave you alone you got
a real problem on your hand and that's
what we have to figure out and i think
that that's what desantis is really
focused on in florida he's going
look biden's ridiculous the federal
government's out of control i can't fix
all that what i can do is fix what's
going on in the borders of my state and
i think that's how we should all be
dealing with the borders of our own
property and and where we want to live
and everything else um so i hope we're
not in one or heading to one but it may
just be inevitable when you have a
parasite in the system that is there to
completely infect the host
what do you do what do you do that's the
question
kyle says is it possible that the left
is willing to sacrifice roe v wade for a
shot at removing right to medical
privacy if roe v wade is overturned does
that put the right to medical privacy in
question so this is a really good
question if you haven't been paying
attention uh there's this mississippi
law that i may get basically to the
supreme court that in the last couple
days there's been some hearings about
and now there is this sudden momentum
will the supreme court actually re-look
at roe v wade again the supreme court
doesn't often overturn their own
decisions but it is not unheard of i've
heard a lot of misinformation about that
it has been done before doesn't happen
that often um roe v wade by the way just
to be very very clear because people are
often confused roe v wade um did not
make abortion legal or illegal it made
it federally legal meaning before that
it was up to the state so it made it as
it made it that the states could no
longer make the decision now this was a
federal mandate that abortion was a
federal
right so look you guys know my position
on abortion i think you have to have a
couple weeks window on this i do not
believe it is a life i think we live in
a pluralistic system with people with
all sorts of philosophical and religious
beliefs and all of those things i am not
denying science we're in the middle of
surrogacy i know that when the sperm
meets the egg guess what happens within
a day basically now because of
all the testing they can do they can
tell you whether it's a male or a female
i know that that's controversial too but
the doctor didn't say oh you know we've
got a male a female and another here you
decide nine months from now
so i'm not denying science in any way i
want to give as much choice uh to the
parents as possible i don't want to
control people uh but i think you have
to have it's just a freaking messy thing
that i don't really want the government
involved in however watching the
abortion extremists on the left who are
you know are basically
calling for eight month abortions and
post-birth abortions and everything else
anyway your question is really about
medical privacy what's interesting about
this is you know our right to medical
privacy has in essence been demolished
already right like look at everything
that's happened with kovid look at the
fact that uh michael over here went to
buy a shirt at bloomingdale's and they
wanted to see his vaccination status uh
whether they were gonna let him buy a
shirt or not he didn't show it to him
and then he had to wear an old shirt
when we went to candace kansas show have
you gotten a new shirt since then oh i
got you a shirt in miami i bought him a
shirt in miami in the hell of a boss
um you want to share too don't you all
right i'm going to get connor's shirt
too that's only fair um but but medical
privacy the concept of medical privacy
has almost been completely annihilated
which is why and i'll be very very clear
about this when i go on tour for my book
i will not perform at any theater that
forces anyone to show a vaccine card
period i'm not going to go to theaters
that force you to wear a mask either if
you want to wear a mask that's fine if
you would like to show the ticket guy
your vaccination status that's fine too
but i will not bring money to those
locations that are doing that in the
states that are doing that that's my
choice uh to do that and if i have to do
all of my shows in florida and texas and
people have to come there to see me
that'll be fine
but i don't i mean think how
hypocritical it would be for me to
be on tour about a book that's about
freedom and to go to states where people
would have to say dave the only way i
can see you is if i show this card and i
also don't think i think you're allowed
to make your own decisions and i
wouldn't want to only perform for people
that are uh vaccinated it's all just
ridiculous so we have to just be careful
man a lot of the things that we used to
believe existed
freedom of speech now with all the big
tech stuff the right to privacy right to
medical privacy right to not incriminate
yourself
etc these things seem to be going away a
little bit we have to act accordingly
madison says can we please stop calling
the communists in america liberals they
have no desire to support an
individual's freedom in any way
madison i feel you look i tried for many
many years to defend liberalism i you
know i think i was like the main guy in
america that made a distinction between
classical liberalism which is about
equality and freedom and individual
rights and laissez-faire economics and
limited government versus bananas crazy
collectivist top-down
uh woke leftism i think i you know i
tried to do that for a long time the why
i left the left video 20 million or no i
think it has 30 million views or
something uh right now like that was my
explanation of all that my book right
over there is a
explainer of classical liberalism um but
what you're really talking about there
is is the way we use words like are the
are the people who call themselves
liberals today
well they're leftists first they're
collectivist verse but are they liberal
no they're they're the most illiberal i
don't know anyone really
uh short of let's say bill maher
that calls himself a liberal that acts
liberally and in bill maher's case he
calls himself a liberal but he votes for
the people who are completely illiberal
the democrats
that's a separate thing altogether um so
for me it's like i don't often say i'm a
liberal anymore i would say i'm a
conservative in that i'm trying to
conserve freedom i'm trying to conserve
america in some ways i'm trying to
conserve parts of liberalism i i've had
talks about this with uh with dennis
prager and ben shapiro and glenn beck
and plenty of other people but yeah the
words have really been destroyed so i i
would say you know look you're either
for freedom for your ability to make a
choice for yourself or you're not
and if you're not i don't want to have
that much to do with you really
but unfortunately going back to that
earlier question they want a lot to do
with us so what do we do about that that
is the question that's something that i
will uh think about for the rest of the
day how about that
uh guys part three of my interview with
brandon tatum is up right now of course
you guys know brandon uh he was uh well
he was the founder of let's go brandon i
just made that up he was he was a former
police officer
uh in uh in arizona and the co-founder
of blexit alongside candace owens just a
great guy good buddy of mine we talk all
about policing and just sort of the the
way the media manipulates certain cases
depending on the race of who shot who
and all the usual nonsense that you guys
all know about the full episode is up
early and ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
and tomorrow
is friday that means we've got a round
trip roundtable extravaganza we've got
josh hammer from newsweek uh my friend
janice dean who's been on the show you
know her she's the fox meteorologist who
almost single-handedly took out andrew
cuomo
and my friend liz wheeler uh we will be
recapping the week that was
uh and uh that's about it for now as i
said there's a lot going on here maybe
some announcements coming some other
announcements i like to kind of lead you
guys that there could be some other
things happening i don't want to say too
much but that's all for this thursday
have a good one and i'll see you
tomorrow